the international court of justice or
icj has been the United Nations main
judicial body since
1946 its main role is handling disputes
between countries not individuals and
its decisions are legally binding but it
also offers legal advice to the United
Nations despite being dubbed the world
Court the icj's role is more limited
than the name suggests it can only
resolve disputes if the countries
involved have recognized its
jurisdiction the court has 15 judges
elected by the UN General Assembly and
the security Council it's led by us
judge Joan Donahue a former State
Department official and her Deputy is
Russian judge Kil gorgian former
ambassador to the Netherlands they all
represent different regions and legal
systems and it looks like this three
seats are occupied by African judges
judges from Latin America and the
Caribbean hold another two three are
occupied by Asian judges five are held
by judges from w W Europe and other
Western countries and two by judges from
Eastern Europe if a country involved in
a case doesn't have a judge from its
region on the bench it can appoint a
temporary one for that case according to
the UN Charter the judges perform their
duties individually not as
representatives of their home countries
in its history the court has seen
193 cases including disputes over land
and Maritime borders and genocide one
significant case was between Nicaragua
and the United States in
1986 when the icj ruled that the US had
violated international law by supporting
rebels in Nicaragua but the US ignored
the ruling and blocked enforcement
action another major case was in
1993 when Bosnia and Herzegovina sued
Serbia and Montenegro for genocide the
defendants were found not directly
responsible Alex beard Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer